>> CLASS WAS HARDER THAN THEY
DESIRED, SO THEY GOT THEIR TEACH
FILED.
NYU, THAT'S SHORT FOR NEW YORK
UNIVERSITY, KAT.
PROFESSOR JONES JR.
WHO TAUGHT ORGANIC CHEMICAL
HISTORY FOR DECADES AND WHO HAVE
WRITTEN TEXTBOOKS ABOUT IT AND
IT WAS FIRED AFTER HIS STUDENTS
WAS COMPLAINING HIS CLASS WAS
TOO HARD.
MORE OF THEM WANTED TO SIGN THE
PETITION, BUT THEY FORGOT HOW TO
WRITE THEIR NAMES.
HIS STUDENTS BLAMED HIM FOR
THEIR GARBAGE TEST SCORES,
WRITING, WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT OUR SCORES AND I
UNDERSTAND AND FIND THAT THEY'RE
NOT AN ACCURATE REFLECTION OF
TIME IN THIS CLASS.
TRANSLATION, WE WERE HOPING WE
WOULD SLIDE BY.
BUT JONES SAID THEY WEREN'T
COMING TO CLASS OR WATCHING
VIDEOS AND THAT'S WHY THEY CAN'T
ANSWER THE QUESTION.
SO MAYBE IF THEY PUT MORE TIME
AND EFFORT IN THE STUDYING
INSTEAD OF WHINING, THEY WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN BETTER GRADES.
ANYWAY, THE STUDENTS ACCUSED HIM
OF REDUCING THE NUMBER OF MID
TERMS, NOT OFFERING EXTRA CREDIT
FOR ZOOM OPTIONS AND FINALLY
TEACHING WITH A CONDESENDING AND
DEMANDING TONY.
CONDESCEND AND DEMANNING.
IF I GET A NICKEL EVERY TIME MY
ASSISTANT CALLED ME THAT AND
MAKE HER CARRY THAT IN A JAR AND
LAUGH WHILE SHE BREAK DOWN IN
TEARS 'CAUSE IT'S SO NOT TRUE.
KAT.
>> HELLO.
>> WHAT SIDE ARE YOU ON?
ORGANIC CHEMICAL HISTORY IS
SUPPOSED TO BE HARD.
IT'S GOOD THAT THEY FAILED
BECAUSE NOW THEY CAN'T BE
DOCTORS.
>> YOU DON'T WANT A DOCTOR OF I
WAS THE BEST OF TRYING TO BE A
DOCTOR.
I HATE THIS IDEA THAT IF YOU
JUST -- IT'S ALL GOES BACK TO IF
YOU TELL KIDS, IF YOU JUST WORK
REALLY HARD, YOU CAN BE WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO BE.
AND THERE'S AN AMOUNT OF
POSSIBILITIES.
THERE'S A FINITE AMOUNT OF
POSSIBILITIES FOR EACH PERSON.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE GOOD AT
EVERYTHING NO MATTER HOW HARD
YOU WORK.
YOU GOT TO TELL KIDS SOMETIMES
THEIR DREAMS ARE A WASTE OF
TIME.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> I WISH I WOULD HAVE HEARD
THAT.
I WASTED SO MUCH TIME PLAYING
YOUTH SOCCER.
I RUN AWAY FROM THE BALL.
>> THAT'S ON YOU.
EVERYBODY NEW THAT WAS A WHOLE
SCAM.
>> WELL, THEY DIDN'T TELL ME.
>> YEAH.
THEY SELL ORANGES AT HALF TIME.
ANYWAY, NIKKI, THAT'S ANOTHER
STORY.
I THINK -- THIS IS -- I WAS
TALKING ABOUT THIS THAT THERE'S
TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
EDUCATION.
THERE ARE THINGS WITH REAL
ANSWERS, LIKE ORGANIC CHEMICAL
HISTORY AND MATHEMATICS AND
THERE'S THE B.S. ANSWER, WHICH
IS WHERE I -- THAT'S THE
HUMANITIES, LIBERAL ARTS.
IF YOU CAN'T B.S. THE ANSWER, IF
YOU CAN'T B.S. FOR X, YOU B.S.
FOR Y.
AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
ORGANIC CHEMICAL HISTORY, YOU
HAVE TO KNOW WHAT X IS.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
>> YOU CAN'T HAVE LAEZ KIDS.
YOU HAVE TO WORK HARD.
NOTHING COMES EASY.
AND THE IDEA THAT THEY'RE
CODDLING THESE KIDS IS NOT GOOD
FOR THEM.
THEY STARTED WHEN THEY GAVE
EVERYBODY A PARTICIPATION TROPHY
AND NOW THEY'RE GOING AND
SIGNATURE, OKAY, YOU COMPLAIN
ENOUGH ABOUT THE PROFESSOR AND
WE'RE GOING TOGETHER RID OF THE
PROFESSOR.
IT'S WRONG.
IF YOU WANT TO BE A DOCTOR, YOU
GOT TO WORK HARD TO BE A DOCTOR.
YOU GOT TO PROVE YOURSELF.
WE ALL HAD TOUGH CLASSES.
>> YEAH.
>> THIS SENDS THE WRONG SIGNALS.
SAW THIS IN OREGON.
THEY TURNED AROUND AND SAID THEY
WERE GOING TO GET RID OF AP
CLASSES BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT IT
WAS UNFAIR TO MINORITIES.
MINORITIES ARE PERFECTLY CAPABLE
OF TAKING AP CLASSES.
IT WAS JUST -- SO THAT WE'VE GOT
TO STOP DOING ALL OF THIS
NONSENSE.
YEAH, YOU GOT TO WORK HARD IF
YOU WANT TO PASS A CLASS.
IF YOU CAN'T PASS A CLASS, YOU
DON'T GET TO BE A DOCTOR.
>> EXACTLY.
SO MAYBE THIS WAS THE WEEDING
OUT OF IT BECAUSE HE LOSSES HIS
JOB.
JAIME, WHEN THE COURT ALLOWS YOU
TO SEE YOUR CHILDREN, DO YOU
NOTICE THEIR STUDYING SKILLS
BEING HAMPERED BY THE PANDEMIC
AS THESE KIDS WERE SAYING?
>> THIS IS PART OF THOSE
UNATTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THE
PANDEMIC.
IT JUST GET OFF WITH A FREE
RIDE.
WE KNEW STUFF LIKE THIS WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
BUT I CAN'T ORGANIC CHEMICAL
HISTORY IS ALWAYS THE HARDEST
CLASS IN COLLEGE.
IT'S CRAZY.
AND I DIDN'T KNOW YOU COULD JUST
SAY IT'S TOO HARD AND THEY FIRE
THE TEACHER.
>> YEAH.
>> I ACTUALLY HAD A SIMILAR
THING HAPPEN.
I HAD A HOT CHEMICAL HISTORY
TEACH AND I WAS ASKED TO LEAVE
TORT SAME REASON -- FOR THE SAME
REASON.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THAT WAS A PRETTY GOOD.
THAT WAS REALLY GOOD.
IT'S TRUE.
IF I KNEW THAT ALL YOU HAD TO DO
WAS SIGN A PETITION, LIKE JUST
SIGN A PETITION AND YOU GET RID
OF A TEACHER.
THAT'S THE 0 THING ABOUT THIS.
IT'S NOT THE STUDENTS'S FAULTS.
THERE'S SOMEBODY THAT GIVES INTO
THE STUDENTS.
WHEN THE STUDENTS SAY I DON'T
WANT THIS PERSON SPEAKING AT A
CAMPUS, IT'S THE PERSON WHO
GIVES IN.
SO IT'S NOT THE -- IT'S ACTUALLY
THE ADMINISTRATORS WHO ARE THE
REAL BAD PEOPLE.
LET'S FACE IT.
IF WE CAN PETITION TEACHERS, WE
WOULD ALL DO THAT.
I WOULD PETITION TO GET YOU OFF
THIS SET.
>> OH, WOW.
I FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE THAT POWER.
>> I DO.
I HAVE THAT POWER.
>> FOR REAL.
THESE ARE -- SOME OF THESE FOLKS
ARE LITERALLY GOING TO BE
DOCTORS.
KAT WAS SAYING, IF YOU WANT
SOMEBODY DASH I'M HAVING MY
HEART WORKED ON AND THE GUY'S
LIKE, YEAH, IT'S TOO HARD, YOUR
HEART, TO FIX.
I WANT SOMETHING EASIER TO DO.
I'M LIKE, WHAT?
IN WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY.
>> THAT WOULD BE AMAZING IF YOU
HAD -- IF YOU WENT TO A
HOSPITAL.
>> VERY SORRY, MR. MURDOCH, YOU
HAVE CACER.
>> YOU MEAN CANCER?
>> YEAH.
NOW THAT HE'S FIRED, DOES HE GET
TO TAKE THE BOOK WITH HIM?
'CAUSE HE WROTE THE BOOK THAT
THEY'RE LEARNING.
IT'S HIS BOOK.
SO THE LAST FIVE WERE HIS BOOKS.
SO IS HE GOING TO TAKE HIS BOOKS
WITH HIM?
>> HE SHOULD JACKUP THE PRICE.
>> ORGANIC CHEMICAL HISTORY, THE
ANSWER IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE THE
SAME.
SO HE CAN TEACH IT UNTIL HE'S
90.
HE WROTE THE BOOK ON IT.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> THIS DUDE LITERALLY WROTE THE
BOOK ON ORGANIC CHEMISTRY AND
YOU FIRED HIM BECAUSE YOU TRIED
REALLY HARD.
>> THAT'S A GOOD IDEA FOR ME.
I SHOULD TRY WRITE A BOOK.
>> TYRUS, YOU HAVEN'T SHOWED UP
IN TWO WEEKS, WHAT THE HELL?
I TRIED REALLY HARD TO GET TO
THE AIRPORT.
I DIDN'T MAKE IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
UP NEXT, ANOTH